[Music]
in almost got away news submitted by Joe
playing GTA 6 we got in early yet but
but it's coming yet yeah there's a fat
okay oh yeah do with six comes out I'm
taking a month off of everything he's
gonna [ __ ] go in by oh it's gonna be
great I'm gonna play story mode first
and then I'm gonna join you on line two
okay let's do this we're gonna have a
[ __ ] game we're gonna run this city
dude yeah right you just gonna go get
hookers and do that for three I'm sorry
not done I have girlfriend online she
was a AI I had a girlfriend on my shoes
really hot
yep she was really hot I'm gonna tell
Nicky and Jess watch play GTA anymore
not anymore
so I don't see her she's probably just
hanging out in my mansion but she told
me she was so hot yeah yeah no I
couldn't get pictures of her cuz she
wouldn't even fit but I know she was so
super super hot speaking of hot two
sisters Oh have been charged with
murdering their father for one sister
confessed to her lover
dude patricide freaking wait hold on I
feel like I need to die so you guys
could raise taken he could kill you one
day because it happens there's a there's
a there's like a percentage that whole
nother thing they're getting abused
so it was like revenge kill yeah yeah
this father do something wrong to the
two sisters to make them feel this it
doesn't seem like it see that's why you
gotta beat the [ __ ] out of your kids so
they always fear you
so the Jerry come right make them into
reeks just kidding no that made me want
to [ __ ] up this is Anthony's not a good
idea
rip 85 years old look like a chicken
nugget poor god poor guy he's dead he's
dead Joe he can't defend himself against
what you just said to him yeah yeah
angry bird I forgot sorry Anthony well
he's dead wait he's the difference with
the sisters of for some reason when I
heard two sisters I thought of like like
teeny so there's 62 and 63 years oh wait
what the face why did they have to kill
him like he could have just died very
soon 62 and it's a murder they don't
like they're a year apart she looks like
the Moon Pie character
I'm so confused damn they hated their
dad that much so it doesn't seem like it
was a hate thing so apparently the
reason why they killed him was because
he had so many health problems he was
gonna die soon and they just he didn't
want to go to a nursing home
yeah so they were like let's just get
rid of him right it's [ __ ] up wait did
he do this no like a cop they're like
that's time he had cancer dementia and
heart problem oh [ __ ] um I would
honestly if I was that [ __ ] up please
kill me you got it you're welcome
jiya will do it yes so they said that
they added too much alcohol to the
mixture and they diluted so he tried to
kill him with sleeping pills and alcohol
but that they put too much alcohol he
got too [ __ ] up and then they tried to
suffocate him hello
but that didn't kill him either God
killing him was they one of them stuffed
a rag down his throat while the other
sister held his nose and arms until he
died that
wow there's a painful way to go why
couldn't they just give him a [ __ ] ton
of sleeping pills or something damn
she's like oh [ __ ] you guys are trying
to [ __ ] kill me you know like the
bother getting the Ragan's here I mean
holy gosh yeah and so he has dementia so
he's not one of the daughters oh sorry
one of the sisters has a daughter an
adult daughter who was at the home at
the time so she gave her sleeping pills
so she wouldn't wake up to catch them in
the act
holy [ __ ] like 40 I don't know daddy
just give people sleeping pills like
that well if they have dementia it's
like here take some of these take some
of these take some of these and I want
thank you i wont wake up in time for you
to kill my dad or grandpa Oh grandpa
yeah maybe she diluted it I don't know
hmm so that the motive was just that
like there's no one like lover I said oh
they ended up meeting some guy a few
years later and after the killing yeah
after the killing because the killing
happened in 2015 they both love Watts
never suspected any foul play at all
because they're even older they were
just like he just passed actually he's
just sold even his doctor was like well
yeah they just put natural causes on the
death certificate they didn't
investigate it cuz they're like he's 85
he's gonna die pretty much what about
all the [ __ ] rag particles are in his
mouth and at the bottom his throat
wasn't it weird when they started
pulling out a rag like it's a magic show
out of his mouth and [ __ ] like that's
kind of weird
I know it's all tied yeah in the [ __ ]
pigeons at the end and it flies out just
that's a good omen yeah I said those
pigeon yeah yeah so then they ended up
not suspecting anything until one of the
sisters they met someone some dude and
then he became lover but then apparently
they're saying that he was both of their
lovers I'm saying they both had a
triangle relationship yeah so then this
dude contacted the police and said hey I
can get you some hardcore evidence that
these [ __ ] killed their dad and so he
ended up getting an audio recording of
the confession yeah why is this guy's
such a [ __ ] no that's great
sorry why did he knock this hard good I
mean it's their murder it's good for the
side of the law I get that okay right
and he's trying to help but maybe he's a
righteous bull why is he such a little
[ __ ] he's a that does not make you a
[ __ ] when you report some foul play
that does not make you happy yeah thank
you I think I think she's been abusing
they've been abusing him probably
what's the real motive I'm saying he's
probably a righteous person like for
example if you go kill someone if I'm
her husband I'm not telling anybody
lover though you're about to find out
let me add something that's what I like
the day the day that he was down to turn
his back and turn into a little [ __ ]
his motive changed so I want to know
what made his motive change because
everyone if you really love someone and
they're friends
you get their back I just wish I knew
more of the story tell me so I can tell
you why the motive might have changed
why he came such a little [ __ ] wait for
this because this do so one of the
sisters she is married and so she
started confessing to the lover that she
wanted to kill her husband and that's
why he stepped in and like hold on these
[ __ ] about do you think probably
supposed to be the side dude I don't
want all that attention on me look he's
probably worried that eventually he's
gonna get killed too so Bart now what do
you say is he a [ __ ] yeah is he a [ __ ]
for narking no because he saved a life
perhaps yeah who saved the future
he saved the future life quickly all
about motorboated and context I was like
you're so [ __ ] ungrateful you're
having a threesome and then later I was
like oh what if they were abusing him
and I'm like that would be a perfect way
cuz if I if it was two against one and
these two little grannies were [ __ ]
me up I'll be so scared
probably grandpa of course they're
abusive they're murder yes so I'm like
I'm scared I don't know what to do yes
I'll go to the police with the reason
like I'm telling like please take them
away they're too scary I know especially
me look like this
have they been convicted that just goes
to show everybody can still find a lover
yeah well so what ended up happening
they said they reported that after their
father's death the sisters and their
brother sold the father's house and
split a 120 thousand dollar profit the
brother was not involved in the murder
no one else knew it's about the money
always um
wait they only got $120,000
for a house they don't live in
California yeah avi they live in Florida
there you go so it's like a 12 bedroom
mansion yep
yeah so the cops are calling this a
perfect murder because they would have
never ever ever caught them if it wasn't
for this dude stepping in and telling
them about the confession you man
there's no foul play dude they could
have waited like two weeks in you in
dead anyway in his age it's like Jesus
actually also why wouldn't why wouldn't
they like give him sleeping pills before
they tried to suffocate him they did
they give him alcohol and sleeping pills
they're trying to oh but they messed up
the mixture but what they were trying to
suffocate him like with the rag cause he
had was all in one night sounds mean
sounds like a bad night yeah yeah and if
it was a perfect murder they would have
gotten on the first try sounds like it
sucked
that one lady look perfect okay murder
yeah huh that one lady looks like a
Teletubby good John the one with the hit
long hair yeah that one looks like a
Teletubby I don't see it which one like
tinky-winky or something they look like
witches the other one looks like a
French courtesan looks like she looks
like Austin Powers she looks like a
professional Mimer she's in France doing
my work
so you're wise eeeh that one lady from
Lemony Snicket fortunate events
unfortunate series of unfortunate events
the one on Netflix the one lady the twin
ladies you guys know what I'm talking
about
anyway gosh imagine like being 16 me
like you know what I think I'm gonna
start to murder now I'm gonna break bad
at 60 that's not a menopause does to you
I don't know you grow a mustache and
become violent dude I'm so scared about
menopause my mom went pretty crazy to
menopause
does she have a mustache oh I never came
in never came in maybe she keeps taking
care of it she could be shaving behind
her back she could be I hope she's not I
hope she's not I hope you wouldn't keep
it
she might be braiding it instead it was
a lot of time keeps you warm though but
no she would like a full blown like mood
swings like within minutes like it was
pretty nice it's like temporary bipolar
yeah Danny put Nicky's so crazy now that
I'm like maybe menopausal actually chill
Nick yeah it could be cool does the
opposite
yeah she could just be the chillest
person on earth after she could be like
that why she doesn't want to [ __ ] you
anymore no they want to [ __ ] way harder
after menopause they do yeah really yeah
cuz your estrogen levels drop and that
the Stas drone takes over and the
testosterone is your your [ __ ]
hormone Wow yeah well that's the it's
your [ __ ] is there a [ __ ] fight
hormone but then the opposite happens to
you your estrogen drops yeah you [ __ ] I
want to [ __ ] I wanna [ __ ] I go fishing
[Music]